pour le président Zelinski la faiblesse
de la Russie est désormais évidente et
ukrainiens qui espèrent également et
surtout tirer les bénéfices sur le front
de cette rébellion du groupe Wagner en
direct de zaporigia près de la ligne de
front justement on va retrouver notre
envoyé spécial Gwendoline de Bono
bonjour Gwendoline Gwendoline avant de
vous écouter on va tout d'abord entendre
ce témoignage vous avez pu vous vous
entretenir avec un membre des
renseignements militaires
ukrainien on l'écoute et on va vous
écouter juste après
pour être tout à fait honnête ça a été
une grande surprise pour nous d'un côté
on comprenait très bien que tôt ou tard
cette action arriverait
vu la gestion de la guerre en Russie
cette cassure dans le système était
inévitable mais on s'attendait à ce que
ça arrive plus tard après des succès
dans la contre-offensive ukrainienne
quand les lignes de front auraient
commencé à se fissurer
après cela on prévoyait cette
déstabilisation
pour notre unité et pour l'Ukraine cette
déstabilisation en Russie nous est
extrêmement profitable une telle
situation est déjà arrivée dans
l'histoire de la Russie et conduit
toujours à la guerre civile et à
l'effondrement total maintenant nous
devons certainement prendre part à cette
action mais cela dépend de la suite des
événements
ces événements nous donnent de grandes
possibilités sur le front également doit
utiliser cette déstabilisation et ses
faiblesses on doit les utiliser sur le
plan militaire et le plan politique on
doit accomplir notre tâche sur le front
et si cette déstabilisation prend plus
d'une semaine notre unité ainsi que
l'ensemble des forces armées
ukrainiennes devront conduire certaines
actions
voilà pour ces propos du membre du
renseignement militaire ukrainien on va
retrouver en direct de zapoidja de la
région de zapporigiana notre envoient
spécial le Gwendoline de Bono Gwendoline
on vient d'écouter justement cette ce
militaire ukrainien que vous vous avez
pu rencontrer qui d'une certaine manière
se frotte les mains de cette de cette
insurrection de de Wagner mais est-ce
que d'une certaine manière il n'y a pas
également une forme de prudence au sein
de l'état-major ukrainien pour l'instant
oui bien sûr ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que l'état-major ukrainien pour
l'instant il regarde évidemment
attentivement ce qui est en train de se
passer mais nous devons faire attention
à ne faire aucune erreur rapide voilà ce
que nous disait également ce membre du
renseignement militaire que vous que
vous venez d'entendre lui pense par
exemple qu'il est toujours possible que
Vladimir Poutine arrive je cite à
étrangler cette insurrection armée
conduite par Yenni Prigogine alors le
chef du renseignement militaire
ukrainien lui dit que Moscou se prépare
à vivre en état de siège il faut aussi
se rappeler un côté ukrainien c'est
important de le préciser que le fait de
déstabiliser de faire des opérations
déstabilisation pour justement
déstabiliser le régime de Vladimir
Poutine ça a toujours fait partie
intégrante de la défense
ukrainienne c'est un axe de la défense
ukrainienne on se souvient par exemple
des incursions des combattants pro
Ukrainiens dans la région de Belgorod en
Russie à l'époque des sources au sein du
renseignement militaire ukrainien nous
disait que tout ce qui déstabilisait le
régime
d'être poursuivi par ailleurs il n'y a
pas de doute tout de même qu'évidemment
l'état-major va regarder les plans de
nouveau pour essayer de voir si ce qui
se passe en Russie créé de nouvelles
faiblesses dans le dispositif russe sur
la ligne de front mais pour l'instant
quand on parle au soldats qui sont sur
leur position et bien leur plan pour les
jours à venir non pas changer et tous
nous disent être concentrés sur leur
tâches sur les opérations qui sont
prévues Gwendoline plus largement quelle
influence va avoir cette rébellion du
groupe Wagner sur le conflit en Ukraine
justement
alors va avoir c'est difficile de le
dire aujourd'hui mais pour l'instant les
faits pour l'instant ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui c'est que les lignes de
front elles ne changent pas on ne voit
pas de ligne de front s'effondrer tout
comme on ne voit pas non plus de
mouvement de troupes russe de rotation
au sein des troupes plus importantes que
d'habitude de la même manière il n'y a
pas d'offensif plus importantes de la
part des Ukrainiens d'assaut plus
important les nouvelles brigades
ukrainiennes qui ont été formées par les
partenaires occidentaux pour cette
contre-offensive elles non toujours pas
été déployés pour l'instant on ne voit
pas un changement dans le rythme de
cette contre-offensive ukrainienne c'est
toujours la première phase la phase où
les Ukrainiens testent les défenses
russes par ailleurs l'artillerie russe
marche toujours les champs que les
Ukrainiens doivent traverser pour
progresser sont toujours miner donc pour
l'instant pas de changement dans cette
contre-offensive pas de changement
majeur et par ailleurs encore une fois
selon des soldats à qui nous avons pu
parler les opérations qui étaient
prévues et qui doivent avoir lieu dans
les prochains jours sont maintenus
merci beaucoup Gwendoline pour toutes
ces explications Gwendoline de Bono
l'envoyé spécial de France 24 zapporizia
en